jouer à des jeux peu importe monstres ou
télécharger des films complets ou de la
musique en quelques fractions de seconde
pour les fabricants c'est la promesse de
la saint jean
mais pour l'instant les appareils
peuvent être deux fois plus cher et les
réseaux commencent à peine à s'implanter
au québec il y à des débuts de 5g
éparpillés dans le coeur de montréal en
beauce
à rimouski mais aussi à gaspé et sur la
côte-nord
quand les réseaux seront véritablement
implanter les cellulaires vont devenir
de 10 à 100 fois plus rapides les
changes des données deviendra
instantanée la 5g ouvre surtout la voie
à la multiplication des objets connectés
jusqu'à la 4g nous apparaît se branchait
des antennes cellulaires qui pour
couvrir tout un territoire émettent en
permanence un puissant signal avec la 5g
on parle plutôt de faisceaux de
radiofréquence qui relie directement
l'antenne et les objets la technologie
pour focaliser la mairie le signal avant
quoi donner au lieu de le renvoyer par
tous et lasseter sur lui en passant de
la quatrième à la cinquième génération
il sera possible de connecter plus
d'appareils en même temps plus de
téléphone plus de voitures plus
d'appareils ménagers dans les maisons ou
d'équipements médicaux ainsi que
d'autres lauper les applications la
rapidité et l'absence de délai de la 5g
a permis par exemple d'opérer un animal
même si le chirurgien se trouvait à 3000
kilomètres de la salle d'opération mais
au delà des promesses et des prouesses
la technologie soulève craintes et
méfiance avec la 5g
serons-nous par exemple
bardé de radiofréquences il pourrait y
avoir une certaine augmentation des
niveaux qui viendront de l'environnement
mais les niveaux sont déjà tellement bas
par rapport aux limites d'exposition des
centaines des milliers de fois plus bas
que les normes en vigueur que cette
hausse ne risque pas d'être
particulièrement significative et la
singer est loin d'être la fin
déjà les chercheurs travaillent à une
sixième génération de réseaux mobiles
ici vincent maison de radio-canada monde